for me cooking gastronomy is a
way of understanding life we ​​know a lot
more than with cooking work for me is
more a mental issue than a question
physical
Y
more than cooking I like to create around
of the kitchen and of these moments also
I like to understand what the kitchen is
but this cooking physically is not
what I really need the most I never
I said that they only do damage to
creativity we started doing
kitchen we did creative and kitchen and
now the truth that we use the kitchen
to do creativity and teacher has
come the slogan is to eat knowledge
to fuel creativity
I was lucky to get a ticket
to open doors that had never been
open for the world to cook what
We were looking for us
the limits that we had what we were doing
We wanted it to be an experience not
single sensory taste or no order
central but an experience I would like
reflect next what you can be able to
get the art field
life in motivation
you knew woman I challenge you I thought that
I knew a lot about society and I realized
that I did not have that much knowledge about
everything did not understand what he was doing
do not
mythical god money because I wanted to
to achieve a homeland of ibiza I did not like
work and this is why I asked all
my life in the way of things one of the
revolutions I was wearing
it is the knowledge of the cooks
conscious amateurs to complete the
mind
the other is to understand that when they come down
remaining not only eat but also
Cook
we have been brave in freedom
I love to talk with painters
sculptors magazines with everyone I
like to learn people participate here
different it is very difficult to focus the
passion when I do the tubes and here's the
home this is the best of my career
in most
I do not understand what people are
understand the days
I love the avant-garde and I love the people who
they risk in the vanguard
that same
the kitchen is a person who does not prick
kitchen
but I cook empty
I'm cooking, I'm with you, I'm
cooking for an hour cooking continues
coming from kitchen cooking action and
this is cooking is physically cooking
this is the least interesting that someone
kitchen
it's not the people
I'm moved by the desire to discover the
world the desire to move forward
want to do different and unique things